une comédienne confirmée comme vous at
elle intérêt à concourir pour un prix
d'interprétation
jean le concours jamais pour un peu
d'interprétation côté d'abord confirmer
ça ne veut pas dire grand chose puisque
chaque fois que nous faisons un film
nous remettons tout en question quant au
prix d'interprétation
ce sont les journalistes qui l'ont dit
parce qu'il ya eu trois films français
sélectionnés
il ya trois actrices françaises valeurs
qui y participent et annie girardot
menant lenzo père et moi donc au point
de vue de la presse écrite sacré une
stimulation audi à compétition bataille
entre ces trois actrices c'est pourquoi
pas un prix pour le film plus important
de voir le film ou bien si on a un rôle
si bien dense et très bien enfin c'est
pas ça qui est important pour moi ma
grande joie c'est que le film my yallop
quels qu'ils soient que les gens aient
plaisir à le voir qu'ils soient émus de
tous la même question de standing pour
une comédienne dans un concours elle
peut y laisser des plumes va il faut il
faut au départ se dire que
c'est que nous on ne le fait pas et si
on le fait bien ma foi ils font
supporter toutes les conséquences